Three,
two,
one.
Got a little thing going on here.
Now we'll circle co Jeff,
merry Christmas.
What's up,
Joe?
You to live it.
Not been the easiest week and in my life
or my career as last week,
but hanging in there to make this a
standalone so the people don't have to
go figuring this out on their own and
I'm sure many,
many fans are 20 and already know that.
The gist of the details.
Let's lay this out from the beginning.
John Jones initial failed test.
Yeah.
So that was July of 2017.
He tested positive for approximately 20,
anywhere from 20 to 60 Pika grams of a
longterm metabolite known as the m,
three metabolite of a substance called
to hydro chloral methyl Testosterone d,
Hcm Tea,
also known as oral to rentable.
And this was over a year ago.
Um,
what was determined to be the source of
this stuff?
Never determined what the source was.
So John went through a full arbitration
hearing,
was never able to determine where it
came from,
tested all the supplements he was using,
you know,
went through many interviews with Usada,
had a full on arbitration hearing.
Uh,
the source was never determined where it
came from.
Why was this suspension so low or so
short?
Well,
it wasn't determined,
so I mean there's many factors that go
into what that suspension was.
I would argue in the totality of the
evidence that was presented in that
arbitration,
that it wasn't a short suspension.
Um,
because really one key thing came out at
arbitration.
So John went to arbitration before an
individual by the name of Richard
Mclaren.
Richard Mclaren has an arbitration group
up in Canada and Mclaren is probably
worldwide known as one of the most
credible guys in anti-doping.
I know you had the ICARUS producer
director on the Mclaren report was the
report that came from all that.
He basically investigated the Russian
state being involved in doping and Sochi
Games and put out actually a series of
reports on it,
detailing that up to 1000 Russian
athletes.
Um,
you know,
we're breaking the rules and the Russian
laboratory was helping them get around
it.
So he's a very,
very respected guy.
He's independent of obviously the UFC.
He's independent of Usada.
He acts on his own and his determination
was his determination,
and I'll read you kind of what he said.
He said,
I find that all evidence available to me
leads me to conclude that the violation
was not intended,
nor could it have enhanced the athlete's
performance.
So a non-intentional so not intentional
ingestion.
I mean there's no argument that it was
in his system that he found the evidence
to show non-intentional use.
And then he went further saying that
based on the numbers of what he saw in
the evidence that was not even a
performance enhancing benefit afforded
to John for having this longterm
metabolite in his system.
And I think that's significant when you
talk about hey,
15 months was that,
that's kind of light being that this is
the second time through.
I would argue that if there was an
argument that maybe it's on the Higher
Ed and certainly,
you know,
we'll talk about the California
commission.
Andy Foster took that position,
uh,
in John's recent California hearing,
he was a little bit critical of Usada.
Um,
he thought,
you know,
he's intimately familiar with is
evidence both in the previous case and
this occurrence that,
and he also saw that there was no
evidence that an independent arbitrator,
you know,
made this a statement and decision of
John Intentionally cheating.
Um,
so if anything,
you know,
I'd say that potentially there could be
an argument that,
that it was on the higher end versus the
lower end because of the fact that it
was an unintentional ingestion.
Exactly.
Now,
what is John's excuse?
What is what it.
John said how he got this into assist.
Yeah.
Well look,
you know,
and it's detailed in the arbitration
hearing at all.
John John fully admits that,
you know,
some of the lifestyle lifestyle
decisions he was making,
you know,
the partying and things,
probably did not lead to making smart
decisions and making smart choices in
terms of what was being ingested in the
body.
But certainly his testimony was under
oath that I have never intentionally
cheated and did not intentionally put
this substance in my body and not only
this case,
but as we talk about the subsequent case
here,
I think you'll see that based on the
numbers,
you know,
coming out of his tests and based on
some studies that have been done on some
of these substances that would tend to
support that.
Okay.
Correct me if I'm wrong,
but didn't John tests negative then
tests positive for extremely low
numbers.
This is the initial test before we get
into the most recent film he did.
So he tested negative then test positive
very shortly after with a very small
trace amounts.
Correct.
So you have two negative tests on July
seventh and July eighth I believe,
of 2017.
And then weigh in day,
I think it was July 28th.
He was positive for a very low level of
the three metabolite and,
and we might as well start here.
So again,
going back to ICARUS,
remember,
remember the doctor,
I mean he's the main character in that
chunk of in 2011,
he put out a study on oral to rentable.
He actually my understanding is dosed
himself and then studied the excretion
of his urine and what was coming out of
it over the weeks and months after and
determined that there were multiple
maybe up to 50 metabolites that once
this Dah cmt was ingested into the body,
the body converted into other substances
and these metabolites stayed around.
He identified some short term,
some medium term metabolites and some
longterm metabolites,
specifically the m three that John's
tested positive for it.
So these longterm metabolites would
indicate that it was taken long time
ago.
They would stay around for the longest.
Why?
Why was he testing negative and then
testing positive for these extremely.
So yeah,
the numbers.
That's a good question and that's,
that's basically the question that
point,
but what was not occurring and what has
never occurred in any of John Sampled is
any presence of the short and medium
term metabolites.
And if you look at a [inaudible] study,
he identifies a couple of these medium
term metabolites,
Roman numeral one and Roman numeral two.
And he says,
these metabolites based on his study
will stay in the body at least 22 days.
Well,
let's look back to the July seventh and
eighth.
You know,
positive tests.
He's negative on July seventh and eighth
for everything,
for the parent compound,
for the short term medium term
metabolites and the longterm metabolites
go 20,
21 days later.
So within that 22 day window,
which is study shows the short and
medium term metabolites would still be
showing up and there's no presence
whatsoever of the short or medium term
metabolites.
Now again,
we'll get into this a little bit more,
but I think the science,
what it's showing is a pulsing effect
for this longterm metabolite.
Meaning once you ingest,
whether intentionally or not
intentionally,
oral Terenna ball into the body,
the body breaks it down,
produces short term and medium term,
which is,
you know,
visible for a short and medium amount of
time.
And then this n three,
which is produced for a long period of
time,
I think with the issue appears to be,
and we'll get into this,
the UFC program is not the only program
that seen this.
There's another professional sports
league that has seen it very frequently.
You sat is also seen this on the Olympic
side,
but we're seeing this strange action
with the longterm and three metabolite
and the theory is it may be hiding in
the fat tissues surrounding organs and
maybe have a pulsing effect where it's
released at certain times and other
times you can't detect it and this is
not the actual substance itself,
but it's a metabolite correct.
Which indicates a reaction to this
substance and it indicates the body
breaking down the parent compound the,
the oral Terenna Ball,
and turning it into these other things
which are stored in the body.
So it's metabolites are not performance
enhancing drugs that are the result of
the breakdown of the parent drug in the
body.
Now,
what,
how much time is it detectable?
The actual drug itself?
So pretty quick,
uh,
it's a pretty quick clearance time.
I think we're Cenk off study says,
you know,
maybe a week,
uh,
so it's not around for very long and
that's why he conducted the study
ironically enough and I was going to go
watch vigorous here last night and I
just,
I've had too much going on in the last
week to kind of refresh mind,
but apparently he,
he knew this was part of his protocol
for Russian athletes.
He knew a coach that was still giving
the oral Terenna ball to Russian
athletes and he had a falling out with
the coach,
so he goes off on the side and studies,
Hey,
the parent compounds is going to get in
and out of the body pretty quick.
It's going to be difficult to detect
that.
Let's try to figure out what stays
around and leaves markers in the body
for a long time.
And so he developed these short and
longterm metabolite tests and was able
to catch some of these coaches athletes
for using the oral to rentable.
Interesting.
So the actual drug itself has gone from
the system,
but the metabolite remains.
Now,
what is the window that this metabolite
is supposed to be detectable in the
body?
Because we're talking now,
what are we at like 18 months?
So here's the show.
Here's the problem is that initial
ingestion,
because my question is these same
longterm metabolites,
these existed a year plus ago.
It was more than a year.
How long ago that,
that's the July 2017.
What was your initial test?
So with all the experts,
and we'll get through this with all the
experts are telling us is there is no
evidence of reinjection and most likely
this is still remnants from the July
2017 tests,
however it was to enter into a system.
Um,
and we'll go through some of these
testing numbers that have shown
negatives followed by very low level
Pika.
Pika gram quantities question though,
was that the ingestion that happened
that he tested positive for in July of
2017 indicated a longterm effect,
right?
It was a long term chart metabolite,
correct.
So meaning it had already been an
assistant for a year,
so it absolutely could have predated,
you know,
the theory the first time through was
something had to have entered his system
between July seventh and July eighth.
Those negatives and this low pika gram
reading on July 28th.
Over this last year,
there's been a lot of study into this
longterm metabolite.
As I mentioned,
this isn't just a UFC issue.
There's another major professional
sports league that for the time being
wants to keep their,
their testing confidential,
but they've shared that information with
scientists,
with Usada,
with myself.
They saw it on multiple occasions.
This pulsing effect over a year where
you'd see this positive test over a
year.
We're two and a half years now,
right.
If it's a year,
if it's a.
If in July,
July 2017 until you were talking a year
and a half,
right?
July 2017.
But it could have been an assistant a
year prior.
I don't know.
Yeah,
it could have been a couple months a
year.
I don't know.
He had never showed up for that end.
Three metabolite for.
He had been tested for it.
He had been tested multiple times in the
programming from wrong isn't the same
level,
isn't it?
Approximately the same Pika grams that
exists today in 2018 that were there in
2017.
Generally if you look and we can go over
these numbers,
it,
it fluctuates from single digit and
never gets into triple digits to mid
double digits,
so there's some as low as nine Pika
grams over that time there was some at
60 pika grams per gram to someone who is
a preposterous.
It's insane.
And you know the.
The analogy that I heard early on was,
and I think John uses throw a pinch of
salt in Olympic swimming pool and I'm
like,
okay,
well that's kind of wrap your head
around.
Now let's go the other side.
Let's talk about something really small
that we know of and how many times you
have to break down that small particle
to get to a pika gram.
So one grain of salt and we all know
what that looks like.
Right?
You put that in front of you and you
split that and I'd mentioned this week,
$50 million.
It's actually 58 million.
If you split that 58 million times a
grain of salt.
Each one is a pika gram.
I mean it's incomprehensible the
detection level and how small that is.
It really is.
It's crazy.
And how many Pika grams did they find in
his system?
So he's gone from,
and I'll,
I'll read through it here.
So here's,
here's since the initial appearance of
the n three metabolite,
here's what John's tests look like and
those Pika gram reading.
So the first one was collection date was
July 28th,
2017.
He had a concentration of ADP programs.
Grams.
However,
let me caution and I'll read something
from,
from an expert when you get down to
these pika levels.
And the science is somewhat inexact
because it's such a small amount.
So the variable,
the plus or minus,
you know,
can be anywhere from 20,
30.
I've seen in some instances 50 or 60.
So what this scientist name,
his name is Larry bowers.
Um,
he was formally the PSA,
the Usada Science director.
He's currently retired and independently
consults before that he ran an Olympic
Olympic Committee,
a accredited laboratory at the
University of Indiana.
The guy's got 20 to 25 years of
anti-doping experience.
Here's what he,
he told me about,
uh,
you know,
when you're,
when you're analyzing small Pika gram
levels,
although the two respective laboratories
report a concentration,
I would caution against becoming too
fixated on the numbers.
First,
the numbers are really estimates of
concentration and probably should be
considered a range of about plus or
minus 20 Pika grams per ml.
And he said the December ninth result
would be in the range of John's.
So we'll get to that between 60 and
102nd.
While the adjustment of concentration by
specific gravity attempts to deal with
the variability of urinary excretion
rates,
it is an exact,
it is inexact and adds variability to
the estimates.
Finally,
most importantly,
science has no clear understanding of
the variance of urinary excretion of
drugs at ultra trace concentration.
So basically saying,
look,
I mean we have a general idea how this
works in science,
but and I think in this instance comes
to play,
be real careful if you're going to be
the guy with the pseudoscience out there
saying,
wait a second,
John jumped from 20 to 60 from September
to December and that means he readjusted
it.
What he's saying here is slow your roll
on that.
That,
that it's such a small incomprehensible
level that we don't really know what
those variances are going to look like.
Now I think if we saw jumps and John
from single digit eight or nine Pika
gram to multiple hundred digit Pika
grams,
there would be a concern and maybe some
re administration,
but the experts I've speaking to when
you're talking variability of 10,
20,
30,
40,
it's not that significant at the peak of
gram level,
what is the window where this longterm
metabolites starts to express itself?
Like what you said,
there's short term and there's medium
term.
This is the long term.
How long does it take for the law?
That's a good question.
I don't have the answer to that and may
be bank cubs report here and I would
encourage those that are home,
you know,
playing playing scientist at their
computer,
a,
the Journal of steroid biochemistry and
molecular biology,
a Rut,
chink of rights,
report detection and Mass Spec
spectrometric characterization of novel
longterm to hydrochloric method,
testosterone metabolites in human urine.
I'm not sure when that longterm
metabolite,
how long it takes to to show up.
Here's the problem though,
with this substance.
He did a real brief study.
My understanding is administered it to
himself.
That's the only study that exists.
Oral Terenna Ball Dah,
cmt to my understanding is not approved
for use for human consumption
consumption anywhere,
anywhere in any country.
So you can't have clinical trials
ethically in the medical world because
it's not legal to give this to human
beings.
So,
you know,
we're,
we're already kind of behind the eight
ball here and that,
you know,
as compared to other substances where
you can do clinical trials because
they're readily available by
prescription or whatever.
The substance is not.
The substance was created by the East
Germans in the seventies and eighties.
And was part of their state sponsored
doping program,
or they were doping their athletes.
Can you correct me if I'm wrong,
but I believe what I've read is that
this is particularly effective when
people are cutting weight.
Yeah.
I mean,
is that true or is this just more.
I don't know about that.
I think some may be confusing Torenna
ball with oral Terenna ball.
Two completely different substances.
Actually.
Very important.
Yeah.
There's,
there's very different effects on the
body.
There's very different windows in terms
of detection time.
Explain that.
Yeah,
you gotta be really careful in this
world of performance enhancing drugs.
There's names that are interchangeable.
There's different,
you know,
chemical names where you change a little
bit of that chemical name.
That could be me.
And a completely different substance.
There's instances where the chemical
name is different,
but the substance is actually the same.
So when trying to compare two
substances,
you know,
make sure if you're at home
doing that analysis,
you're comparing the right ones.
Straight Terenna ball is different than
oral to rentable.
What is the difference?
Uh,
yeah.
I can't tell you,
I'm not as familiar with Terenna ball
other than it's not oral to rentable,
so,
but there is a difference in terms of
the detection window.
Yeah,
there would be,
I mean,
different substances create and throw
out different metabolites and different
substances have different detection
windows.
So I haven't done my study and research
on straight to rent a ball other than
knowing it's different than the
substance here.
So,
uh,
Gregory Rich hank off,
that's how you say his last name,
right?
He was the only guy to do an actual
verified study.
Correct.
Now has this study been,
is it been peer reviewed?
Yeah,
I mean it,
it's published in
the Journal of steroid biochemistry and
molecular biology.
So in order to get something published
it needs to be peer reviewed.
So it's hasn't been replicated anywhere.
Not that I'm aware of.
No.
So it's just.
So we have one study which is really
fascinating.
So we know that,
first of all,
we know this is an effective steroid.
We know it works.
Yeah.
The East Germans I think showed that
they wouldn't be a,
have been using it.
It's not a difficult,
it's not an easy,
easy substance to get ahold of.
Look,
when it's not approved for use anywhere
in the world,
um,
it's only available on the black market,
so you'd probably have to go to China to
get it manufactured or you know,
research chemical supply company that's
not supposed to be provided to,
to humans.
Now,
I'm certainly not attributing this to
you,
but there were rumors.
This was one discussion.
Was that one of the possible ways he
could have ingested this?
Um,
and the speed very kind.
John Likes to party.
Okay.
One of the things about partying as
people do cocaine,
and one of the things about cocaine is
sometimes cocaine is cut with creatine.
One of the things about creatine is
oftentimes you're buying cheap creatine.
I spent like one of the things that
we've had with on it on,
it's our,
our products are all third party
verified,
but in the initial goings,
when we tried different manufacturers,
especially for Alpha brain,
we found there were other trace elements
that were in Alpha brain that weren't
supposed to be in there.
And it's because of the vats that they
mix these things up with and one of the
things that we had heard was that
creatine oftentimes is made in the same
place where they might be making oral
Terenna Ball,
they might be making antibody,
they might be making a bunch of
different things and trace amounts of
this stuff can get into the creatine and
they use creatine to cut cocaine with,
is this,
is this possible or am I just.
Yeah,
it's.
It's absolutely a theory.
I don't know.
I,
I can't sit here and say that happened,
but I will have heard similar things.
I have heard some more things.
I know for a fact,
based on my previous career,
I worked closely with the DEA.
I was with the FDA.
I worked cases involving street
distribution of recreational drugs
including cocaine.
I know for a fact that creatine is one
of the most common substances that
cocaine is cut with because I look some
more color,
some more feel.
So getting back to
Mclaren's arbitration decision,
I mean this is publicly available
records so I'm not saying anything new
but it Mclaren addresses at least John's
lifestyle around this time and he says
the athlete openly admitted to Usada
that prior to and for a period of time
after the reporting of his second
adverse analytical finding on July 28,
2017,
the athlete used illicit so called
street drugs including cocaine.
Now for me to sit here and say that's
where it came from.
I don't know that he's talking about the
athlete admitted
that prior to and for a period of time
after the reporting of his second
adverse analytical finding on July 27,
2017 admitted.
So before that test and sometime after.
Okay.
So does that make sense though?
If it's cut,
that's what were the source of it is?
Does it make sense that that would show
up as a longterm metabolite?
Doesn't it need a long time in the body
to digest or do we not know enough about
the window of time?
Yeah.
I don't know if we know enough about the
window of time.
You know,
my,
my theory and looking at it is even if
there's a small amount of the oral
Terenna ball in that it's going to for a
period of time,
show that parent compound at a small
picogram amount in the short and midterm
metabolites in the small Pika gram
amount.
We have never seen those in the history
of Johns testing.
It's only this longterm metabolite.
So that may be indication that it
occurred.
Maybe even prior to what we're talking
about here.
Is it something that could be
accentuated in some way by the weight
cutting process?
I absolutely think that could be a
factor.
Um,
there are studies not necessarily with
this,
but another substance clomiphene and
look,
I want,
while I'm cautioning people to be
careful about comparing different
substances,
the commonality between Clomiphene,
which there are multiple clinical
studies on because it is approved for
use to be distributed to humans and oral
Terenna ball is they're both chlorinated
so they both contain a chlorine atom on
the molecule and there is a recently
published study on clomiphene and its
excretion rates again,
for those at home that want to look it
up.
The study was published in the endocrine
society publication.
It's pure reviewed.
The name of it is hpt axis effects and
urinary detection following clomiphene
administration and males.
So what they did is they basically,
you know,
got a group of males,
um,
gave them a one month cycle of
clomiphene,
you know,
I think 25 milligrams a day and then had
them get off and then continue to look
at the urine up to 261 days after.
And what you saw and what you see in
this study is that pulsing effect.
So,
you know,
I'm looking at some of the study
subjects here.
Um,
subject one on day one,
21 still showed 147 Pika grams of
clomiphene day one,
28 showed 174 pika grams.
Day One 35 shows nothing.
He's below the minimum courting a
reporting limit.
And then day one,
49 is back up to 2:36.
There are one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six out of I think 12 subjects in that
study that showed this pulsing effect of
this chlorinated substance coming and
going.
Again,
you know,
it's,
it's different than oral Terenna Ball,
but it has that common factor of being
chlorinated in this study.
They do talk about,
um,
a fat tissue called the,
let me look this up and make sure I got
this right.
Adipose tissue,
this is fat that surrounds the internal
organs.
It's one of the last things that the
body burns when it's going,
you know,
starving itself and going to fat.
It protects those organs.
But yeah,
you look at these,
you know,
extreme weight gains and cuts that the
UFC athlete goes through.
I don't think you're going to find
possibly another human subject anywhere
that goes through putting weight on,
other than maybe that I don't think
Olympic wrestling matches with an MMA
fighter,
um,
goes through,
at least in my experience over these
three or four years talking to those in
the Olympic world.
I think we're at the extreme and it's
something obviously we've talked about
before.
We're trying to curtail,
but you know,
there's,
there's clearly never been a study for
anybody who dehydrates and readwrite
hydrates themselves to the extent that
some of our athletes do.
You could never find that would never be
anybody with any ethics that would
support a study because some of that
dehydration exceeds World Health
Organization standards.
So there's no studies out there,
you know,
on this stuff.
But clearly,
you know,
looking from afar I,
I'd say that it likely has some impact
over what's being released by this
adipose tissue.
We should certainly talk about that in
the future,
about the week cutting aspect of it.
So the,
but this adipose tissue loss at extreme
weight cuts could potentially be the
reason why this stuff is excreting
itself.
It's,
it's definitely a theory out there.
What about microdosing?
So here's the thing with microdosing
microdosing has done with endogenous
substances,
so only test it.
Well,
I mean someone could try it with
something else,
but the reason you microdose with
endogenous substances is there already
produced in the body.
Right?
So the theory of,
okay,
I'm going to microdose oral terminable,
well,
oral terenna balls still producing these
short term and longterm metabolites in
theory,
whether you're taking 100 milligrams or
one milligram of oral Terenna Ball,
those excretion rates of those
metabolites are still going to be
consistent.
They're going to be in a much smaller,
lesser a way to those excretion rates.
Is there a way to mask that in some way?
I'm not aware of any.
Go ahead.
I'm sorry.
The only study we have is Gregory,
correct?
That's it.
Correct.
But you know,
just taking it from a common sense
approach.
It's certainly those that know about
micro grossing,
know that you microdose with indogenous
substances,
things that are already appearing in the
body so your body knows what to do with
them,
knows what to do and you're fooling,
you know,
not only are these metabolizing and
there's no metabolites of them,
but you could also be fooling the
biological passport.
That's the concern I think and why
people microdose.
So you saw it as looking not only
testing for specific substances,
but our testosterone epitestosterone
ratio is going up.
They're looking at at blood values,
how many young red blood cells,
how many mature red blood cells.
So microdosing and those two areas
wouldn't set off alarms in the
biological passport world.
Um,
I've never heard personally of
microdosing of exoticness substances
that are not found in the body
microdosing.
And my understanding is done with things
that are endogenous body for people that
are not familiar with this terminology,
we're just talking about microdosing
performance enhancing drugs because a
microdosing in today's world is a very
common thing with mushrooms and Lsd and
a lot of.
I mean,
I saw a ton of microdosing in the
cycling world that was tested for
testosterone epo,
Hgh,
all those natural occurring in the body.
And so they don't produce any really a
red flag metabolites if you do them at
very,
very small levels,
they'll,
the parent will clear quickly not
produce any metabolites and will not
throw off the biological passport
analysis.
Um,
is there a,
what you mean when Victor Conte came out
with a clear and all that stuff with
bulk?
Whoa.
They were fooling people.
Is it,
is it,
I mean,
one of the things we've talked about
before is that it's a constant race to
try to keep up with more advanced
cheaters.
It is.
And you know,
what's interesting in this,
I mean,
without to talk to you and maybe the
first time we did talk a couple years
ago,
um,
it's come a long way from them,
but clearly if I've ever talked to you
15,
16,
17 years ago when I got my start in the
anti-doping world,
I would have told you definitively the
testing is way behind what's being used
out there.
Um,
they were testing,
able to test to multiple nanogram
limits.
That's as far down as we can go.
Now they can go down to single digit
Pika Gram.
There's another professional sports
league out there that recently had a one
pika gram and three metabolite case.
I mean do the math coming down from,
you know,
four or five nanograms,
which used to be the lower limit now to
one Pika gram 10,000,
20,000 times.
I am almost under the theory that the
pendulum has swung maybe a little bit
too far in the other direction and that,
that certainly is part of my job to the
UFC.
Look,
I want catch every intentional cheater
that's out there.
I want to make sure we have a rock solid
program.
Use all the latest and greatest,
you know,
um,
techniques to do it.
But I also want to keep an eye on it to
make sure it's being administrated
fairly.
And when you're getting down to the
detection of one,
you know,
single digit Pika grams.
I have a concern that what kind of level
of sensitivity we're talking about.
Are we going to talk about environmental
contamination where you walk through a
room and somebody has just opened a
container of something and there's,
you know,
minuscule powders in the air.
There are documented cases that some of
the regularly prescribed prescription
drugs,
specifically,
um,
diuretics are getting in water supplies
in some areas.
You know,
you get a lot of old people on them that
flush their old pills down the toilet.
There's documented cases of it getting
into the water supply and being
detectable at that peak of gram level.
So you've got to be really,
really careful about that.
And I think,
you know,
this case exemplifies that you saw it
and really the world antidoping agency
world and community are aware of that.
Um,
you know,
with greater sensitivity and testing in
my opinion because you know,
makes greater responsibility to be
objective and look fairly at what really
we're doing here when we're detecting in
that small amount.
But this,
this test of John's where he's testing
for the same level of peak of grams
today as he was in July of 2017.
Is it safe to say that this is
unprecedented?
Repeat that again,
that John's test for the same levels of
peak grams of these metabolites in 2018
that he was testing for in 2017 with
this is unprecedented.
No,
the answer's no,
so maybe unprecedented in the UFC
program,
but what the United States anti-doping
hhc did over these last five or six
months as they reached out to the
science community outside the scope of
the UFC,
they reached out to other professional
sports organizations.
They reached out to other to
laboratories and what they were seeing
was multiple instances of this pulsing
effect where over time you would see a
reading.
The next test it would go away and the
next time you'd see that reading again
maybe back up to or even above this much
time was correct.
Yes.
So you see that in the.
In the clomiphene study here too,
I mean almost 260.
They stopped the study,
what it was still appearing and Pika
gram levels in some subjects and they
stopped the study at 261 days and you
see those numbers.
I was reading to you see this one
subject at one 74,
he's negative the next time and then he
pops up to two in the two hundreds
after.
So it's actually more than the time
before.
Again,
apples and oranges,
different substances.
But the commonality here is chlorinated
substance.
So is it safe to say that this is an
emerging science and that we're still
learning and understanding this as we go
along?
Absolutely.
It,
it's still very young.
Look,
the first,
you know,
the 1984 Olympics in Los Angeles were
the established the first drug testing
laboratory by Dr Catlin.
Um,
so really,
you know,
in the scope of science going back to
the earliest days,
then they're talking about,
you know,
what,
30,
30 years,
35 years.
Um,
again,
when I started off in this 16 or 17
years,
the science still wasn't good.
They were unable to detect anything in
the Pika gram level.
Um,
again,
for,
for reference.
Very interesting.
So the water,
the world anti-doping agencies accredits
laboratories across the world and they
have certain standards that those
laboratories must meet or to retain that
accreditation.
Um,
and keep that accreditation so they have
a technical document called the minimum
required performance levels of their
laboratories.
So would they tell the laboratories as
you must detect these substances down to
this amount?
If you can't get them down to this
amount,
then you can't have an accreditation
from water.
So the class of substances that oral
Terenna ball would be in,
um,
which would be other anabolic agents,
the required minimum level that they
must detect two is only two nanograms.
So look,
why did he even says,
as long as you can get to two nanograms,
you can retain our accreditation.
Well,
what's happening is an arms race in
these laboratories.
They're saying,
well,
the twos,
the minimum standard,
but I can get down further and you know,
these are private entities that are
looking for,
for customers.
So to be able to reach out and say,
well even the law tells us to is as low
as we need to go.
We can go down to one pika gram.
I think in a sense,
maybe you need to slow the reigns on
that a little bit.
That we're getting too far and too
sensitive of a level of detection when
it comes to implementing a fair program
because you can't determine where a pika
gram ca came from.
You could be breathing again,
contaminated air,
drinking contaminated water.
It gets real dangerous when you get down
that low.
The how does this reflect on past
suspensions?
This is what when you deal with someone,
look,
let's bring up Frank Mir for example.
Didn't Frank Mir also test for oral turn
a ball.
Okay.
I want to get back to Frank Mir,
but let's.
Let's go back to John and this instance
and why you saw that has come out and
said,
look,
this is not a violation.
So if you go to the water,
the world anti-doping code,
there's a section 10 point seven,
point four,
point one are UFC program basically
mirrors that and we're bringing that up
on the screen there.
So for purposes of imposing sanctions
under tab 10,
point seven and anti doping rule
violation will only be a second
violation.
If the anti-doping organization can
establish the athlete or other person
committed the second anti-doping rule
violation after the athlete or other
person received notice pursuant to
article seven,
etc. This is what's known as a double
jeopardy clause.
Be sancTion guy tests positive for
something and if he's test positive for
the exact same substance that is still
in his system a year later or whatever
the amount of time is,
you don't include that as a new positive
test.
One more thing has to happen.
Science has to determine that there
hasn't been a real administration so
test positive for the same substance and
science says,
based on all the numbers we see,
there's no evidence of any readminister
ration and the non evidence of the
administration is the lack of short term
and medium term can go and never ever.
And john cyran issue though that this is
only one test that gregory would cenk
[inaudible] test is the only study that
showed that these medium and short term
metabolites exist.
It it's the only study,
but I think then if there's only one
study,
you have to go to anecdotal evidence.
Right.
Do studies on ufc employees because
they'll do it.
Oral to rentable is illegal to
distribute.
Go in any country throughout the world.
It's really legal.
Contracts go.
They just let you do whatever you want
to do.
I don't know,
maybe we can look into that,
but shelby maybe up for that.
That's the reason for living there.
Um,
I,
I have a problem with that in that we're
relying on one study.
This seems to me to be like a critical
thing that could affect.
I mean we're,
we're,
we're hoping and we're,
uh,
we're putting faith in this study that
this is the only way that these
metabolites express themselves.
Is it possiBle that,
what,
that,
theSe,
like you see what the pulsing effect
that you see positive effects and
negative or positive results and
negative results that these short term
and medium term metabolites don't always
express themselves and that what we're
considering a longterm metabolite could
in fact just be a metabolite.
Yeah.
I mean I guess it's possible,
but what do you,
are you going to sanction an athlete
again because you know,
potentially it's possible.
And then the theory of the universe,
you can't do that.
Let me read to you real quick what,
what these experts came out at in terms
of administration.
So Dr. Daniel eichner runs the salt lake
city.
It's called a smart sports medicine
research testing laboratory,
or myrdal.
They're one of two water accredited
laboratories in the United States.
You have the one being at ucla,
um,
again,
one of the most respected minds in
anti-doping phd,
chemist,
I'm his answer in terms of readminister
ration.
Um,
was this.
And you very rarely see scientists at
his level talk in a absolute in
absolutes.
There you go.
And here he says,
there is no evidence that dah cmt has
been readministered that's in writing to
us.
So very definitive on that.
Um,
you sought as science director.
Now danny daniels independent even of
usada.
So those who criticize,
hey,
you saw it as in bed with the ufc.
Daniel lackner doesn't work for usada.
He runs an independent laboratory.
Usada send samples there.
The nfl send samples,
they're major league baseball,
send samples there.
The ncaa,
he's independent,
owns his own laboratory.
Um,
usada also put out a letter to us in,
in writing,
um,
upon careful consideration of the very
low concentration of the dh cmt longterm
metabolite and Mr. Jones is sample and
taking into account the human pharma
kinetic characteristics of this
particular longterm anabolic steroid
metabolites,
uh,
based on data to which you saw it has
access to and in consult,
in consultation with scientific experts,
some of whose opinions are enclosed,
you sought as concluded consistent with
prior residual amounts detected.
And Mr. Jones sample that the presence
of dh cmt longterm metabolite is
consistent with residual amounts from
exposure prior to July 28th,
2017.
I'm,
look,
I'm not an expert.
I don't profess to be,
um,
my background's in finance and
accounting.
I traced the money back in the old days,
but I know who those experts are out
there in the world and these are them.
Um,
they're my putting these things in
writing,
putting their reputations on the line
now and forever going forward.
Um,
they're never going to do something like
that because you know,
the ufc pays you saw to administer our
program or because jon jones is a
popular fighter and they want to see him
fight this weekend.
That's just not the way this world
works.
Of course in in fact,
it works the opposite way.
There would be a great benefit if they
could catch him cheating.
Absolutely.
And you know,
historically experts like this are very,
very conservative when it comes to
talking in absolutes like this.
They don't normally do it.
In all fairness.
The real question is guys like you and
me because we are ufc employees so we
can handle this fairly and get that
argument,
you know,
and I saw that left and right that hey,
jeff and joe are paid by the ufc.
Of course they're going to come out in
this way,
but look,
all these things that I'm reciting today
ever do that in regards to cheating,
I wouldn't either.
I've,
I side with the ufc and a lot of things
because I support the sport and I want
it to excel.
I don't side ever with cheating.
If I think that there's some way somehow
that someone is given an unfair
advantage and this is somehow being
covered up,
I would rather not work for them.
Joe,
my,
my seventh,
my last 17 years of my career,
my,
you know,
everything that I've worked for is to
protect the rights of clean athletes and
to eradicate cheating from the sport.
I can't tell you how strongly I feel
about that given me everything in my
life.
My dad was a high school basketball
coach,
um,
it paid for my college and scholarships.
It,
you know,
at least the good characteristics in me
I can all trace directly to sports and
entering into the equation the issues of
breaking the rules,
the issues of the health and safety
aspects when you have young.
And I talked to many parents whose kids
use steroids because they saw the
professional athletes doing.
Entering that into the body when your
hormonal levels are already out of
control is very,
very dangerous.
Both short and longterm.
Can't tell you how passionate I am about
this issue.
And those out there that are saying that
I'm corrupt and my reputation is out the
window,
I would never ever in a million years
listening to those people.
I mean you obviously you have,
but you can't listen to those people
because they want to find things wrong.
I'm.
One of the things that I've said about
you is you're a guy who loves to catch
people cheating.
You like it,
you enjoy it.
That's not true,
man.
You do.
I don't mind if someone is cheating and
you catch them.
well,
you know,
in the ufc program now with what we've
established here.
Absolutely.
Back in the old days,
and we've talked about this.
Look when you had in baseball or in
cycling,
no testing going on.
Literally the Organizations were looking
in the other direction.
I've often said that,
look,
I don't agree with what they did,
but there's a portion of me and that's
why I think a lot of these athletes
respected me and share that information.
There's a portion of me that said,
I don't agree with what you did.
I'd like to think I wouldn't make the
sand decision,
but I damn well understand why you did
this.
You're fighting for millions of dollars
in contracts,
you know,
your teammates are doing it,
your competitors are doing it and you
know,
you're professional sports organization
doesn't give a shit because of the
weakness of the testing program or total
lack there.
Uh,
So in instances like that,
there was,
I never came away saying that guy's an
idiot or an asshole for choose.
And I came away saying,
kinda get why he did it.
If I was 21 or 22 years old and
immature,
I may have made the same decision.
Now come into our program here where you
have an organization that cares very
much,
that spends multimillion dollars a year.
This program has done nothing but costs.
The ufc money costs us money and how we
implement the program costs us money on
canceling fights.
Anybody who thinks moving this fight to
California is that a financial benefit
to the ufc is crazy.
We're taking a bath on this one.
People really do need to understand that
the ufc decided themselves.
They self imposed usada as say,
sanctioning of fights.
Correct.
Nobody forced us to do that,
so this is a.
This was a big step in the right
direction of trying to make the sport
cleaner because we recognize that first
of all,
there was some legal stuff with the
testosterone replacement therapy that
just threw everything out of whack right
where it was.
Essentially it was sanctioned.
Cheating.
I mean,
let's be honest about what that was.
it was.
It was clearly a my understanding being
manipulated.
Yes,
very easy to manipulate when you get
permission to use any prohibited
substance like that.
And we went from that to unbelievably
strict protocols and now what you're
seeing is you're seeing,
first of all,
we saw a radical change in the physiques
have some fighters where we did have
some suspicions and those suspicions,
at least in my eyes had been confirmed
and now we're seeing the good side of
this with what in your estimation might
have been moved over into a position
where,
okay,
now now it's getting a little bit
ridiculous in terms of like what we can
detect and what is what is causing
fights to be cancelled.
Exactly.
So interestingly enough,
the world antidoping agency or water,
they're next code revision is 2021.
And so they regularly put out,
hey,
what are the issues going forward that
we want to address?
And one of the major issues is
potentially establishing thresholds for
these low level substances that keep
appearing.
Um,
dah cmt being one of them,
austrian being one of them.
And so the idea that water is looking at
and has a working group of worldwide
experts is,
hey,
if if something that gets reported back
at under 50 pika grams,
all the evidence is showing,
more likely than not,
this is from a very low level
contaminant issue.
We've never seen an issue of microdosing
or an intentional use that's reached
that level.
Why are the labs even reporting at sub
at quantities lower than 50 pika grams
or 100 peak grams?
I think very soon they're going to come
out with a recommendation.
We are going to adopt that before 2021.
Once that working group and we're in
communication with them,
comes up with those recommendations.
You'll see it implemented first in the
ufc program.
Again,
I've always said fairness,
due process in a program is just as
important as the strength and
comprehension,
comprehensiveness of that program.
You'll lose faith in your athletes.
You could have the strongest loophole
free program in the world,
but you start implement ting things
unfairly.
You'll lose faith just as much as if you
had a bunch of loopholes and the
program.
It's got to be fair.
Are you aware of the female skier that
tested positive because of lip balm?
Uh,
I think,
yeah,
it's vaguely recall about that.
What was someone else use the lip balm
before her?
No,
no,
no.
It was a,
uh,
a lip balm for sunburn.
It was for sunburnt lips and it had some
ridiculously small trace amount.
Was it austrian cve?
Her name is jo jo burg.
Trying to remember her name.
Well,
there was the,
the cocaine kissing defense was actually
won an arbitration.
So something similar.
Somebody tested positive for,
you know,
low level metabolites of cocaine and
basically said,
look,
you know,
hey,
whether that was good or not,
but um,
you know,
the arbitrator bought it and the science
shows,
hey,
that,
that is a possibility.
The detection levels are so low.
If you kiss somebody who had just done
cocaine,
they are now able to detect at those
levels,
in the person that kiss that person.
That makes sense.
Do you find this woman doping label on
the label?
Which is why they gave her a penalty
apparently.
Oh,
I see.
Okay.
What is the,
um,
who fucks reading labels on lip balms?
You know what I mean?
See,
that's how crazy it's gotten.
I mean,
all our athletes know when,
when they're using a creatine or a
protein or whatever,
I think most of them are pretty careful
right now,
but to tell them,
hey,
you need to read your lip balm and your
deodorant.
I mean,
where,
what level of we get into here?
And these levels of detection.
So she 29 year old star of norway's
powerhouse squad of skiing,
cross country skiing,
tested positive for an anabolic agent
listed in the contents of a treatment
for sunburn.
Um,
this could be similar in some ways to
what Chad mendez tested positive for,
for something for psoriasis,
correct.
Sat Chad mendez has obvious psoriasis.
You'd see it on his body.
He's talked about it pretty openly and
you use some sort of a cream and
accepted his penalty.
Wasn't aware that this cream had
something,
some type of a steroid into it.
Yeah,
I had seen him publicly state that now
he chose not to present a defense or go
to arbitration.
So I haven't seen anything in detail to
review.
He just wrote knowledgeable opinion on
that.
Yeah,
he did.
Um,
what.
So let's get back to the frank mir case.
Frank mir tested positive.
Was it also also same thing,
longterm metabolite of world to
rentable.
here's the difference.
Frank mir the same as John Jones.
His first time through was sanctioned.
John didn't get off the first time they
showed up in his system.
He got,
you know,
he was looking at potential for years,
went to arbitration,
presented evidence,
enacted some other clauses in the policy
that reduced his sanction.
What does that mean?
Well,
one of them was a substantial assistance
where he assisted usada in some way,
shape or form,
and he got a reduction for,
for doing that.
Assisted in what way?
So I don't know,
and this is the exact reason why I do
this.
So I insulate myself from that
interaction between usada and the
athlete.
They are the sole,
a dirty jew,
decatur in this.
They do not,
you know,
get me on the phone,
say,
hey,
we're thinking about going this way.
They adjudicate completely in a vacuum
and you are,
you're just so people know your title is
safety,
health and safety,
athlete health and performance.
Vice president of athlete health and
performance.
Yeah.
So you no longer work for you saw?
I've never worked for usada.
That's,
that's a big misconception.
A lot of our fighters think that I've
never worked for it.
I was a federal agent for 22 and a half
years.
I'm the latter part of my career and got
involved with all these ped distribution
cases.
Two thousand 15 fertitta and dana white
through a mutual friend contacted me and
said,
hey,
would you come out and kind of talk to
us?
We're contemplating maybe putting our
own program together.
We've had some recent high profile
positive,
so I came out to vegas a talk with them
and a week later I get a phone call
asking if I want to come work for him
and kind of implement this new program,
but I've never been an employee of
usada.
OkAy.
So that's.
That's good to know because that's been
stated by some public figures that you
used to work for usada and now you work
for the ufc.
Shale was one of my favorite words.
Um,
so you never worked for usada you,
uh,
brought usada to the ufc or communicated
with usada and facilitated this
agreement?
Correct.
So I,
I'd never worked for you sada.
I did work very closely with usada.
So you saw that when I first started
these series of investigations back in
2002.
Look,
I knew all about how to work a heroin
distribution organization and cocaine
distribution organization,
methamphetamine,
but when it came to performance
enhancing drugs,
there was no class that myself or really
any other federal agent or law
enforcement agent goes through
surrounding distribution of performance
enhancing drugs.
So I was examining the discarded garbage
of balco every week when they put it out
to the curb,
began seeing notes,
rappers,
all these substances.
I had no idea what these things were.
I didn't know the difference between
testosterone,
epitestosterone,
erythropoietin,
hgh.
I knew nothing.
So what I did is I figured out who those
experts were,
who were the people that could very
quickly get me up to speed on what I was
looking at.
Um,
dr catlin,
who ran the ucl olympic loud one of the
first and he started,
um,
you know,
kind of walking me through this,
he put me in touch with usada and you
know,
they began educating me as well.
So,
um,
over the course of those investigations,
I got a lot from them in terms of
educating on these substances.
They were bringing some of their
cooperating witnesses to me and then we
go off and running on criminal
investigations but never,
never worked for them.
So you sought to correct me if I'm
wrong,
but the way they would work would be
very compartmentalized.
Like they would not specifically
communicate with you on all of the
details of this.
Correct.
And they don't.
Now pendants aspect,
I don't as these deliberations are going
on,
what they're looking at,
I don't know.
It's cooperation.
Just for me to be frank would in my
eyes,
would mean that something was done
purposely illegally and this person had
some knowledge of purpose,
purposeful,
illegal aCtivity,
and that they would somehow communicate
this to facilitate some sort of catching
of someone involved in a criminal act or
an act of cheating.
Yeah,
that would make sense to me too.
He said that would be what we were
talking about.
Usada would allow john a shorter if he
actively participated in helping them
catch people that were cheating,
that that's the understanding.
I don't know.
Implied implied.
I don't know to what level that was
done.
I don't know if it was that or if it
was,
hey,
here's how this drug works.
In more general.
Here's.
I don't know what it was.
I purposely that would mean that john
would have to know about cheating.
If you were saying like this,
this is how this drug works.
This is how I used it.
I mean this would he would.
That would mean his initial defense
would have to be thrown out the window
because it wasn't an accident.
Well,
I mean,
I don't know about that.
If you knew something separate from,
you know,
that he wasn't someone else.
Yeah.
And again,
I don't,
I don't want anybody to reach that
conclusion.
I have no idea what his substantial
assistance entailed.
None.
Um,
and that's a slippery slope.
It is a slippery slope and look,
transparency's important in any program,
but you know,
only to a certain level.
Look,
if you are transparent about what
everyone's,
you know,
cooperation or substantial assistant was
and the whole world knew about it,
you're never going to get anybody after
that coming in and,
and,
and cooperating.
I saw this definitely on the criminal
side with informants.
You don't,
that's not something that's that you
want to be transparent about or
disclose.
Right.
But there's going to be a bunch of
people that have a real issue with that.
The idea that jon jones,
you know,
one of the greatest fighters of all time
is actually working as an informant.
I mean it's,
it's listed in the,
in the,
you know,
in the mclaren's ruling that that was
one of the reasons for the mitigating
factor in the reduction.
But I don't,
again,
joe,
I know to leave that alone.
Nothing about it.
It's been stated.
We know what it is.
Okay.
Or what we know that it's a thing.
Um,
when it comes to the john's initial test
where he was sanctioned and was
suspended for a determined period of
time.
Frank mir also was sanctioned and was
for a determined period of time as well.
He was two years.
He was.
John was shorter than that.
John was shorter and cooperate on a
bunch of other to fail.
So you,
you,
you not only cooperative,
he went to arbitration and put on a
defense.
He put on a defense that,
look,
the evidence here shows no intentional
ingestion of it,
and in fact that claire and gave him a
further reduction based on.
There was no evidence of this was
intentionally done.
Frank mir didn't put on any.
He had every right to go to arbitration
put on his own offense.
Didn't do that.
What about josh barnett?
Josh barnett,
you know,
a completely different set of facts.
His came from a contaminated supplement.
It was a different substance.
He went to an arbitration hearing.
The arbitrator ruled with josh and said,
yep,
you know,
based on where we are now based on the
care and effort that you took your
right,
you deserve to earn to have time served
at the time of that arbitration.
So again,
I think that's a good example of the
checks and balances in place here.
You've got me overseeing the program,
taking a look at how these things come
out.
You've got the ability from the to go to
mclaren's group and judge,
you know,
the set of facts.
And in that case mclaren's group said
usada,
I think maybe overreached a little bit
here and I believe josh and josh is,
you know,
basically time served.
So you know,
you'd want to see,
you want to see them get it perfect
right every time.
But you know,
and the reality and the real world is
that doesn't necessarily happen and
that's why you have these checks and
balances available.
I'm josh barnett.
Take on.
The matter is that they tried to paint
him as guilty even though he was not in
that he,
he feels like he definitely got a bad
deal and that he was labeled as someone
who is taking this substance.
He was suspended for a long period of
time while he was going through this and
although he was found not guilty that he
feels like not enough emphasis was put
into establishing that he was not guilty
and that he,
he feels like they chased him down over
something that you didn't do.
Yeah,
I mean,
well,
here's what he did do is he used a
supplement that if he would have
listened to anything that we educate on
that you saw to sends out regular
reminders are fighters are required on a
quarterly basis to go through videos and
their whereabouts,
filing that deals with these issues.
If he would have followed any of that
advice when it came to his supplement
choices,
you would have never chosen the
supplement he used.
I,
you know,
when,
when I heard about that supplement and
what was on the label and how it was
marketed,
I said,
okay,
well that's,
that's likely the candidate of where it
came from.
So I mean,
the analysis would be,
hey,
you know,
that pool will be careful.
There's sharks swimming in that pool.
They can eat you and the person jumps in
the water anyway saying like,
I didn't want to get eaten by a shark,
but shark comes up and ate them.
It's like,
hey,
we told you that this was the case.
You didn't follow that.
Now there also needs to be a
differentiation between someone who's
intentional cheating,
intentionally cheating,
and someone that's just,
you know,
makes a naive supplement choice there,
there needs to be a differentiation
between that.
And there was,
in that case,
josh didn't get,
you know,
the full penalty of what was,
what that substance would have rendered.
But he did have to go through a long
period of time where he was unable to
fight.
He did.
But,
you know,
again,
he had the prohibited substance in his
body.
Um,
as you saw it,
it has to look at,
hey,
even though you did that,
didn't do that on purpose,
did that give you a performance
enhancing benefit?
Did it allow you to recover a little bit
better?
Did it make you a little bit stronger?
And you know,
that's why those strict liability
provisions are in there.
Otherwise people would just take these
prohibited supplements and say,
oh,
I didn't know exactly it was just
accident.
Exactly.
Meanwhile,
they're getting a benefit for.
Exactly.
So they have to have some sort of
penalty in place.
I think so.
Now I also think,
again,
there needs to be a differentiation
between the intentional not intentional.
And we do have that in our policy.
There are definitely mitigating factors
available in our policy that if you
didn't do things on purpose,
you're not,
you're not sanctioned as hi.
Tim means is a great example there.
So tim means used a relatively benign
supplement.
It was a creatine,
creatine,
you know,
generally doesn't have an issue as,
as,
as opposed like testosterone booster
supplements.
We tell our athletes stay away from
anything marketing as a testosterone
booster.
It's one of the most common with
contaminants are purposefully spiking
purposeful spikings to means use a
creatine.
It had a austrian and in a very small
amount,
uh,
we found it in their australian is the
two year sanction.
He got six months,
um,
you know,
so back relatively quickly.
So I think that's the thing with yoel
romero so correct.
Yoel romero used a natural diuretic
product that had a psalm in it.
I'm in all these cases,
not only does the prohibited substance
need to show up and what the athlete has
says they've used our ready to eat,
but to protect against making sure the
athlete isn't purposely spiking it,
you saddle will go out on their own,
on the market,
independently procure,
hopefully the same lot of product.
And in the case of joelle and tim,
they were able to do that,
test it completely independently of the
athlete,
determine what level of the prohibited
substances in that,
based on the interview with the athlete
of how much did you use,
when's the last time you used it
relative to this test,
do the science calculations just to make
sure an athlete's not saying,
well I know this creatine is spiked with
australian so I'm going to go use
austrian and then I have a built in
excuse when I test positive for
australian in order to be able to match
contaminant levels with what's being
excreted in the urine.
You would literally have to have phd
chemistry degree and I'm not aware of of
any of our athletes have in that.
It'd be very,
very difficult to do that.
And so these detection levels,
again,
we're talking about nana grams.
We're not talking about large quantities
that would work pika grams grams.
Okay.
Correct.
Now what,
why was,
why was this moved from vegas to
California and why?
Why did the California state athletic
commission,
why did they accept this fight taking
place here?
And why did vegas say no to it?
So internally the ufc wise,
we first,
in fact donna marcaine,
who you know who works with me,
a shout out to donna.
Exactly.
We're a two person shop and the woman's
a hawks and one of the hardest workers I
know.
So she's.
She's awesome.
She's taken a look at something that we
have access to called the clearinghouse
and it's basically a recording of all
the tests on our athletes so we can get
on there.
Somebody says,
hey,
how many times was john tested last
quarter?
We can get on there and pull that up.
The public also has access to our
testing records,
not with a specificity that the
clearinghouse has,
but the public can get on and you saw it
on a weekly basis.
Updates how many tests and athletes
done.
So there's some of these,
some guys out there on the internet from
the day one of the program have kept
track of what week they're numbers tick
up so you can go find spreadsheets on
the internet at least from a,
from a weekly basis of when our athletes
were tested.
Now many times every week,
god bless those dorks.
Crazy,
huh?
So the clearinghouse program is very
specific.
We can get on there and see the actual
date of the collection and next to that
we see negative,
positive or pending.
So donna came to me late november,
early december saying,
hey,
I'm looking at john's tests and I'm
seeing pending still back from,
it was maybe august,
september.
I think something's going on here.
And of course I'm like,
okay,
well he's fighting pretty soon.
I hope not,
but let me reach out to you sada.
So I reached out to them.
They said,
we're working on something,
we're conducting a study,
we're talking to other professional
sports leagues,
we're talking to the laboratories out
there and don't have an answer for you
now that,
but stand by.
So I think it was a december six.
They sent a letter to us and they sent a
letter to the Nevada state athletic
commission saying,
just so you're aware,
over the last six months,
um,
early in this six months,
we've seen a reemergence of this
longterm metabolite in john's samples.
We lost was this.
So this was early december,
December 6th,
um,
we and the Nevada athletic commission
were notified.
You were notified,
but the test was from previous.
Just so the tests,
these tests,
I'm covered from august through
november.
Okay.
So there's white test.
Several of them.
Oh,
so more than one test showed this
metabolite.
So what they said was August 9th,
negative August 29th,
eight pika grams,
September 18th,
eight,
eight September 18th.
So I mean there's a,
there's a good.
So he's negative on the ninth,
20 days later.
So inside the 22 two checkups,
22 day window,
he shows an eight pika gram,
no short term metabolites,
no longterm,
no parent,
no medium term,
no medium.
I'm sorry.
No medium and longterm.
Thank you.
Um,
we then go to the 18th of September,
19 pika grams.
And then that's followed by four
negative tests,
September 21st october,
second,
October 11th and November 14th.
So at this point,
late november,
early december,
you saw it says,
okay,
we've done our studying those two low
levels in august,
our residual,
there's no evidence of any real
administration based on lack of short
and medium term.
And parent based on our consultation
with other leagues with these labs that
are seeing this,
we're calling this,
this is would be double jeopardy if we
did them again.
Okay.
So this is something that should be
really emphasized because there's a lot
of people that don't understand this.
This is not just this one test.
These are many tasks that have been done
over the course of john suspension and
then ultimately relicensing that are
showing this exact same metabolite at a
very similar level that according to
previous tests,
specifically on clomiphene,
that this could be this pulsing correct
result of existing and not existing.
But this is not indicative in any way
that can be provable of microdosing.
Correct.
And not only that,
but this is over.
We're talking about this being over long
term,
long periods of time.
Many months,
yes.
Okay.
And consistent numbers over many months.
Yes.
So,
and again,
going back to what one expert Dr. Bauer
said,
you've got to be careful what you're
talking about.
Single double number rams.
And you see some variance.
You got to be careful about saying,
well it went from nine to 18.
That means real administration,
no,
it's inexact science at that level.
The water labs,
this is a non threshold substance,
so all his water requires them to say,
to report back to water,
positive or negative.
They're not required to quantify.
However,
these water labs,
I've also realized there's an issue when
you're getting under pika grams.
So what they're doing is going back
after reporting the positive,
hey,
let's see if we can estimate with this
level is it's an inexact science at pika
gram quantities and my understanding,
um,
to estimate what those levels are.
Okay.
You can see some variations.
So Nevada is unwilling to sanction the
fight based on all this information.
So they get,
they get the initial notice that we got.
Also,
I think it was december six saying,
look,
there was an issue in,
in august these longterm metabolites
reappeared.
Appeared again.
But we've since had four negative tests.
We don't believe that the august,
you know,
reappearance is a re administration.
There's no sanction here.
Nevada,
you don't even have jurisdiction over
the august test.
Again,
keep in mind these are ufc tests.
Nevada doesn't mandate it,
but Nevada says,
look closer to a fight.
We do take jurisdiction.
We will adopt these usada tests.
So you saw it didn't need to to notify.
They thought out of an abundance of
caution,
let's let Nevada know that this issue
exists.
Goddamn usada what they said,
but wait,
that's all good.
And you saw that it gets this.
I talked with them.
They're like,
whoa,
this is,
this is concerning,
but we don't see anything within our
jurisdiction here.
So I certainly hope that no subsequent
tests show up positive because that
could be an issue.
And sure enough you saw to collect a
sample from john on 12,
nine,
they expedited the results because they
knew the fight was coming up and they do
that now when fights or clothes or the
collections are done close to a fight
and here,
you know,
he pulses back up to uh,
between 60 and 80 pika grams.
So Nevada gets this.
Uh,
this was last week,
man,
the days of run together for me.
So,
uh,
a week ago,
friday we have in a bob bennett who's
the executive director.
While I'm a big fan of these great guys
talked shit about Nevada,
but I remember fbi agent so we gotten a
ton of ground.
He is.
He's one of the reasons why it probably
wasn't sanctioned in Nevada was because
they're so by the book.
I get angry because I wanted to fight to
be in Nevada,
but I understand bob's position that
implicitly so.
So let me make clear what happened.
Bob came in,
Anthony Martin elle,
the chairman of the commission came in
and a couple representatives from the
vat attorney general's office.
So they are the ones that prosecute and
cases involving ped use at violates
Nevada regs.
So we share all this with them and list
like you did with me.
Correct.
Share it all with them and look,
there's some misconception out there.
They did not say this fight absolutely
not happening next week.
In fact,
they,
I think we're understanding these
issues,
but said,
look,
you know,
optically,
this doesn't look great and we feel that
out of an abundance of caution that we
need to have a public hearing and be
very transparent about this because this
is.
This is some weird shit.
Um,
this was last friday,
so we're eight days out from the fight,
so,
you know,
we start talking about,
hey,
when can we potentially have this?
And unfortunately christmas holiday,
several of the commissioners weren't
even in town and basically what they
said is,
look,
we will absolutely do this if you want
us to,
but likely that hearing would not be
until tuesday,
thursday or maybe tomorrow,
friday.
And you know,
marinello is like,
look,
I,
I'm starting to get my head around this,
but I can't guarantee you that my other
commissioners or me are going to come
out the same way.
So you're taking,
you're taking a chance here that,
that we could say,
well,
we need more information.
So.
So basically they were willing to listen
to it.
Um,
I think they were starting to wrap their
heads around it but didn't feel that
they were up to speed enough on it.
Um,
they didn't have the luxury that andy
foster and California have.
Remember when john tested positive in
July,
2018,
that fight was in California because
that fight was in California,
California retained jurisdiction.
They've had two very public hearings on
john when they suspended his license and
most recently a week and a half ago when
they reinstated his license.
So andy in the commission,
we're very familiar with the world
termina ball.
They were very familiar with the
longterm metabolite and in fact andy was
somewhat critical of usada during the
last hearing.
He thought after looking at all the
details after reading,
you know,
mclaren's a position that there was no
evidence that this was done on purpose.
He thought,
man,
maybe they went a little bit hard on him
and he stated that in that,
in that second hearing.
So with the reemergence of the pika gram
quantity of this m three longterm
metabolite andy in the commission,
unlike Nevada,
didn't need to get up to speed on it.
They've already had two public hearings
on john's issue.
They were intimately familiar with some
of these dynamics of this drug and the
metabolites and,
and that's why he felt comfortable based
on their familiarization with it and
based on these written absolute
statements by these experts.
So there was no real ingestion one.
And then the second thing which we
haven't covered is these experts said,
based on these low level pika grams,
there's no performance enhancing
benefit.
And that's an important point because if
you would've told you fc look,
this is still remnants from a year and a
half ago,
but we can't rule out that he's not
getting a performance enhancing benefit
from it.
Well,
in that instance I'll tell you,
and you know,
I,
I stand by this I,
w I would leave this company if somebody
told me otherwise,
if there was any indication that there
would be a benefit from him,
even though it technically wasn't a
violation,
I'm not going to stand by while anybody
licenses that guy to fight could have
been.
Could this have been somehow or another
mitigated by communicating these results
to Nevada earlier?
Well,
we didn't announce the fight that john
was going to fight and in Nevada until
october,
but in october.
So you have said,
hey look,
here's this issue.
Sure.
Potentially.
But the issue was you saw that hadn't
come to that they were in the middle of
that point of consulting with other
professional sports leagues with the
other water labs.
They hadn't reached their conclusion
there.
Science expert hadn't determined,
hey,
this is definitely residual.
No performance dancing.
They were still going through that data
at that point.
So what they've told me is,
look,
we tried to hurry that along as fast as
possible.
We wanted to make sure that,
that we went through this and very,
very detailed and no stone left
unturned.
When,
when did they reach this conclusion?
This.
So this was early december.
So December 6th,
that letter went out saying we've had
these two low level positives back in
august.
We're okay,
but here we are.
I mean this is the end of december.
What could this have been headed off at
the pass?
Well,
again,
when Nevada first got notified,
they thought like,
we were hoping,
well,
he's had four negative tests,
so he's probably going to be negative
going forward here,
right?
I mean,
that's what,
you know,
the lay person would think,
okay,
he's probably out of the woods now,
but you know,
again,
getting back to what period of time is
this in john's preparation and if you
look at some of these numbers and when
these metabolites appear and disappear
in early august,
john was preparing his defense for this
arbitration.
I think he had an idea based on talking
to his attorneys like,
hey,
we got a pretty good shot here of some
mitigating factors where this is
potentially going to get reduced.
So I think,
you know,
he starts to get a little bit motivated,
gets in the gym,
starts training again clearly in early
december.
That's a period of time when our
fighters that close to a fight are
bringing down that body weight right
there,
cutting body fat,
they're losing a little bit of water.
So it certainly seems to correlate
these,
these pulsing effects with when this
theoretical right,
that close tissue.
Absolutely it is.
So,
uh,
this positive result was announced when,
so a week ago yesterday as you saw it as
announced,
sought notifies us the ufc.
That always happens.
And they notify if any commission has
jurisdiction at this point.
This close to a fight.
Nevada has jurisdiction.
So I get the call and you can imagine
what's going through my head.
I mean,
I,
I've gotten so many of these calls now.
I literally,
for the first five or 10 minutes,
can bury my head in my hand and think
through exactly how this thing's going
to play out.
And you know,
it's going to be,
hey,
nevada's going to say,
wait a second.
What's going on here?
We need to root this out.
John's going to say,
jesus christ,
like,
what is going on in my life?
I can't get a fucking break.
I'm trying to be careful.
I even went through with dc how dc is
going to react and he reacts.
He's going to be.
I fucking told you this was the case.
This guy's a cheater.
You know,
you saw it as bullshit,
novitsky bullshit.
All this stuff goes through my head and
the first five or 10 minutes,
what's,
how's dana going to react?
How hunters are gonna react when I have
to go over to his office and explained
this out to them.
It played out exactly as I saw it.
It's,
it's,
it's some of the worst days of my career
when I get these calls.
Um,
but you know,
every bone was notified and in Nevada
was in our office two days later.
And again,
I mean,
there's been some criticism of them out
there.
I don't fault them.
This is a complicated issue that
optically doesn't look great and to do
anything in a rush manner would be
difficult.
They did everything they could to afford
us.
Having a hearing problem was,
it was just,
it was too close to a fight.
So essentially to get this out,
this issue with optics,
right?
Because if you go on twitter,
everybody's calling him a cheat.
Everybody's saying that you know,
anybody that sanctions this is your
sanctioning cheating for someone to get
an understanding of what this is like.
It actually requires probably more than
we've done now over the last hour and 15
minutes.
Yeah.
And I appreciate this forum.
I mean,
dana and I went on sports center and
announced it in three minute hit and I
came out of there going absolutely
everyone in the world's going to say,
this is bullshit.
You can't.
This is what.
We're going to have a hard time doing
this in two hours here,
mrs.
Yeah,
you've got.
You've got to delve into it and you've
also have to put your trust and reliance
on these experts.
They have a education professional
career of 20 to 25 years to come up with
these absolutes.
There's no one else in the world,
but maybe a dozen people that can come
up with these conclusions.
You do have to put your faith in,
in their background and their careers
and their knowledge and education and
you know,
read those absolutes were that there was
no evidence of any reinjection.
This is by multiple experts and that
john would not have retained any
performance benefit based on these low
level pika.
Gram amounts.
Well,
I'm happy that we were going to have
this out there so people,
if they have the time,
if they're really that interested in it.
This is probably a more in depth
discussion of this then you're going to
get anywhere else,
but I really wish we could have gotten
something like this to Nevada and Nevada
could have gone over this and looked at
what,
what I'm saying,
what you're saying.
It seems to me that we could have just
had some sort of a meeting and kept his
fight in Nevada and it would have saved
everybody a lot of heartache.
Yeah,
I mean I think things were pointing in
that,
but there was no guarantees on that dice
baby.
It's still come on.
It's vegas.
You know.
The other thing that was being looked at
was was fairness to these athletes.
Really you're going to.
You're going to put john and gus maybe
more importantly in a position where he
doesn't know until two days or a day
before whether this fight is happening
or not.
I mean these and not even mentioning the
other fighters on the card and look,
you can talk to and I have to sean and
mick and dana and hunter.
All these fighters want to be on the big
paper reviews.
They know the bigger the fight at the
top of the car,
the more eyes are on that fight and when
you have a spectacular fight in the
first second fight on the card,
if it's on a big pay per view with a
giant fight at the top of it,
that can propel your career,
your next fight,
you could be fighting the main event on
fight pass and progress from there.
So I think,
you know,
I think it's accurate to say that
generally everybody wants these,
these cards to be as big as possible and
when all the experts are telling us a
hundred percent,
this isn't a sanction be he's not
retaining any performance enhancing
benefits.
I think,
and clearly dane and hunter thought
this,
we have an obligation to do what we can
do for fairness for john.
Definitely for,
for gus,
for the rest of the card to try to make
this fight happen going forward.
Is there any way we could ever prevent
something like this from happening again
with a similar situation in place like
Nevada?
So here's.
I think we have a couple solutions to
that and it's not necessarily relative
to the commission,
but one thing that obviously protected
john a lot,
and this was the frequency of testing.
If you look at his numbers and these
were these were instances where they
collected samples,
but in many of these cases they did
multiple tests on him and that means you
know,
the tests I'm reading were for the
anabolic steroid panel,
but in addition to that,
they may have done the biological
passport tests on that same collection
that may have done in hgh test and epo
test and this is all confidential that
you sought.
It doesn't release all this information
with these numbers on the publicly
available website that you don't see
what those tests are done.
So the reality,
and they just told me this is john was
one of the most,
if not the most tested athlete over
these last six months.
When you look at total amount of tests
on samples,
excuse me.
One thing that obviously protecting them
here was that volume of testing.
And so you saw to came to us and said,
you know,
hey,
we think that you probably should,
you know,
up the amount of tests that you're
doing.
So,
um,
we just renewed a contract with usada
and reduced.
We're increasing our testing numbers by
30 to 40 percent.
We currently,
uh,
the first three years of the program
were under contract for approximately
2,700 tests and starting this next year
we're going to up that to around 43,
4,400 tests.
So I think there going to be more of a
burden they're going to be,
you know,
you saw to showing up in more doorsteps
early in the morning,
have more of our athletes.
But I think this is a perfect example
that,
that increased volume of testing
actually can be a protectant to the
athlete,
especially when you talk in these low
level pika gram quantities and
contaminated cases and things like that.
We just got to get athletes to stopped
taking any supplement.
It's not third party tested.
Great point.
So here's what we've done in that area.
So about three months ago you saw a
hosted a working group.
It included the ufc,
myself and our nutritionist clinton
wattenberg,
who you've met,
were there major majorly baseball,
was there,
the department of defense was there,
there's been war fighters who have
purchased supplements at bases over in
Iraq and Afghanistan that contain
ephedrine and other bad products.
Some of them potentially have died as a
result of ingesting them,
so they definitely have an interest in
safety and dietary supplements and you
saw it as experts were there.
What we did is we invited in the major
third party certification companies and
each one took a half day presenting what
their programs look like.
We went back and huddled after each one
and huddled at the conclusion and said,
what is a platinum standard third party
certification look like?
Let's all these presentations we got
what was and one's weaknesses and the
others and we have to put a perfect one
together.
What was it?
What does it look like over the last
month we've been offering,
um,
a paper that's going to be published in
a scientific journal going over with
that gold standard platinum standard.
Looks like I'm going forward any third
party certification company that can
meet that and there's some that are very
close.
I think we'll be able to do it very
quickly.
We are going to say,
you saw it is going to say this is an
approved line of supplements.
We approve you to take this and this is
something that we've been unable to do
in the first three and a half years of
the program and I tell you,
joe is the most common question I get
from our athletes.
What's you sought approved and as soon
as I say you doesn't approve any
supplements,
but here's how you ensure your safety.
They stop listening.
Goes in one ear out the other.
This is a silly suggestion,
but why doesn't the ufc come up with its
own supplement and provide them to the
fighters and say,
you can't take anything else.
Yeah,
I mean it is after they've been through.
It's had sponsorships with other
supplement line.
Exactly.
There's a lot of dynamics to it.
It's not as easy as doing it overnight
and distillation method.
Just if you could say,
hey,
you can take creatine,
you could take,
you know,
all the multivitamins,
you could take a branch chain amino
acids and all these things that have
been proven to be effective,
but that's weird too.
Right?
It's like they're effective.
Meaning they enhanced performance and
recovery,
but they don't do enough to be
considered a performance enhancing drug.
Yeah.
And their president in the food supply.
So like basically out of community you
can go eat 10 chicken breasts or you
know,
have a couple of scoops of protein if
you're on the go and don't have time to
do it.
So I think again,
apples and oranges in terms of
performance enhancing or not.
Um,
so the theory would be we have an
approved when,
when I'm or dawn or asked that question,
what's approved,
I can say here's,
let's say nsf nsf has 1200 supplements
that are approved.
I'd say all 1200 of these or approved.
You should only use these.
If something were to happen to an
athlete that used and approved line of
supplements to get out of jail free
card.
If they can prove it.
And you saw it independently,
prove it.
There's no sanction.
I think that is going to go a long way
and I'll give you a reason for that.
Major league baseball does that.
They have for the last couple of years
now they have some advantage and that
all their athletes are employees and are
coming into the same facility for during
the season.
So they have some control over there.
Well we don't.
Our athletes are spread amongst 46
countries throughout the world,
so it's more of a challenge.
But baseball's said the only supplements
we're allowing in the clubhouse or in a
facility are.
They use nsf supplements.
They had zero contaminated supplement
cases last year they had,
I think they're testing numbers were
four times the amount of our testing
numbers and zero contaminated
supplements.
I mean the proof's in the pudding right
there.
So they had worked with deal with nsf.
I don't know if it's a deal other than
they've examined who those certification
companies are and they feel that they're
at the top of the line.
We don't want to exclude any.
And that's why we're contributing to
this paper to say,
look,
anyone could be one of these approved
lines,
but you must meet this criteria for
platinum standard program,
but it's coming from someone who's in a
supplement business.
Me,
that's the wild west out there.
Boy is it.
I mean there's a.
There's a lot of shit out there that's
just.
They purposely add performance enhancing
drugs to their stuff because it's cheap
and people take it.
They experience these gains and then
they sell a lot of it and then you get a
following.
Exactly.
I saw that when I was with the fda,
there is what they normally will do for
maybe the first six months of the
product.
They'll spike it with something if
they're going that route and then to
decrease liability thereafter.
They've already got the following,
stuff's working like like hell,
and then they back off just in the
government and it doesn't work.
And people go,
oh my body must have adapted exactly
this.
It's really such a shame because this is
such a fantastic fight.
I mean there's so much drama involved
already.
Just having John Jones returning,
having alexander gustafson looking
absolutely sensational in his last fight
with glover to sharer all the trash talk
and hype and intensity in the fact that
this is really other than dc versus
john.
This is the fight that people want to
see in the light heavyweight division,
and look,
nobody's saying that.
I'm certainly not saying that john
didn't do anything wrong.
He obviously did.
John has two times now tested positive
for prohibited substance,
says however,
in both occasions,
arbitrators have determined that it was
not done intentionally.
So anyone who says that,
oh,
john's getting off light on this,
he's been suspended for almost two and a
half years,
for lack with a lack of evidence of any
intentional use are cheating.
You know how much money he's probably
lost in those two and a half years.
How many tens of millions of dollars
doesn't reputation?
Anybody who says that he got off scot
free on this?
I would argue the otherwise he was held
to the strictest of liability standards
out there.
Someone at the top of their game,
money earning potential like him.
There's also an incredible amount of
stress and,
and it's on him just a human being,
he feels and he hears what people are
saying about them and that's,
that's got to be very difficult also,
again,
coming off of this massive suspension.
So he's coming off of the suspension,
which was huge,
very public,
very worldwide after the cocaine,
the car accident,
the,
the previous,
the dick pills that had the stuff and I
mean this is so many things.
And then to have this happen literally
the week of and have the fight moved to
California.
I mean,
and I get the skepticism that's out
there.
Again,
without delving into this,
I've spent hours and hours and these
experts have spent their careers looking
into that.
That's really what's required to get a
comprehension and understanding of it.
Um,
another thing,
another argument,
john's being treated specially because
he's john,
but we had another athlete that this
somewhat identical thing happened too,
but nowhere near at the level of john.
So a kid by the name of grant dawson.
So grant dawson last summer was in the
data white contender series,
had an awesome fight.
Dane is like,
you've got a contract kid.
Uh,
we get them into the usada program that
we,
you solder quote program requires you to
disclose everything you've used going
back 12 months or one year.
The idea being,
look,
even though you weren't under the
program,
if you've used,
you know,
oral terenna ball eight or nine months
ago,
there could still be an advantage that
you'd be getting,
you know,
we're not going to necessarily suspend
you because you weren't subject to the
program then,
but we're not going to let you fight.
All right away.
You're gonna have to be in the program
for a certain amount of time testing
clean.
So he didn't,
he didn't disclose that he was using
anything.
His first test,
he tests positive for m,
three metabolite low levels.
He goes to arbitration,
argues,
testifies under oath.
I've never heard of this substance.
I've never taken it.
I would never cheat.
Here are all the supplements I was
using.
I can't find it.
The arbitrator.
Here's the hearing you saw.
It goes to them and says,
hold on a second.
We're looking into this matter talking
to baseball,
whatever you sorta comes out that,
hey,
we can't prove that this didn't enter
his substance a year before that
disclosure required him to disclose what
he was using,
so he was basically lead often an
eligible,
so john's not the only person in the ufc
that this has happened to,
not not withstanding other professional
sports leagues,
other olympics.
It's happened to other athletes.
He's not the only one.
So I think what's important for people.
I get the skepticism,
but I think it's very important that
people don't accuse someone of something
that they didn't do and I want you,
if you're listening to this,
I want you to imagine if you're John
Jones and you trying to get your shit
together and you didn't do anything new,
he didn't do anything different.
We've got to have a path of redemption
for people.
You've got.
You have to.
And if john,
as you're saying,
and all of these tests conclude,
if he didn't do anything,
folks,
you've got to stop saying he's cheating.
You got.
He's not cheating if he's not cheating
and if it's showing that these are these
longterm residual metabolites that are
an incredibly small dosage,
it's there's a real cheaters out there
and john's fucked up.
He has fucked up and you were all right
to be upset at him when he fucked up.
This is not his leases.
My conclusion after talking to you and
and and I've,
I've talked to some independent
scientists that were skeptical about
some of the aspects of it,
but they're also,
they're skeptical because they're not up
to date perhaps on the differences in
this pulsing effect or the fact that
this is something that is relatively.
There's not a lot of,
a lot of documentation on this.
I mean this is something that's
relatively new in terms of our ability
to understand pika grams.
Our ability to understand this pulsing
affect all these different,
these variables that you have to take
into account when it comes to this.
People love to call cheat.
They love to and it's good.
It's good that the people were out there
keeping people honest,
but I think you gotta we gotta look at
this the right way and I think the right
way is what you're,
the way you're laying it out here,
I don't see any holes,
so a couple things in the future that
people can look forward to.
Look,
we want and john wants to fight in
Nevada and Nevada is basically said,
look,
I think we understand this issue,
but we need to have this hearing.
There will be a public hearing on this.
My understanding is early quarter one,
so look,
you know,
don't take word for it.
Wait until
january.
I'm sure they'll call some of these
experts to testify.
Introduce some of these documents into
the public record longer even than this
conversation.
Yes,
that would be my guess.
Yeah.
Um,
so yeah,
I mean that's,
that's to come.
The whole thing is such a disaster for
everybody else on the card for Amanda
Nunez and cris cyborg and for all the
people on the undercard.
I mean,
it's just to have them to move all the
way to California when I'm happy about
those that the fight is still happening,
I'm very happy to fight is still
happening.
I am.
And again,
I have to take an objective look about
is this fair as it relates to how our
policy and what the rules are and you
know,
when you have,
you know,
one of the experts in the world,
Dr. Daniel lackner,
other myrtle laboratory issue an
absolute statement like there is no
evidence that dh cmt has been
readministered and that based on these
low levels,
he does not retaining a performance
enhancing benefit.
How out of fairness and implementing the
program,
do you prevent this from happening?
You can't do that.
It would be categorically unfair.
Um,
moving forward from here,
what changes and what do we do to stop
something like this from happening
again?
I think the increased volume of testing
is going to help.
I think being able to specifically
direct our athletes to approve line of
supplements will help.
Um,
but you know,
hey,
we can don and I can message the hell
out of these things.
But you know,
it,
it takes the athletes and their camps to
listen to what we're saying.
So I mean if anything good comes out of
this,
hopefully it's a warning to those other
others out there about how careful you
need to be.
So just to wrap this up so people
understand if you,
if you want to put a button on this,
there is no evidence whatsoever of any
microdosing.
So this is one of the concerns people
were worried about microdosing no
evidence whatsoever of microdosing
wouldn't be a substance.
You were generally microdose.
You do endogenous substances,
not exotic enough is also no evidence of
the short term and medium term.
A medium,
a medium term.
Yup.
Metabolites that were recognized by
virtue of that.
Say his name again.
I think it is gregory.
I have a tough time with Gregory Gregory
caligari.
That's the only test we have no parent
compound ever found as well.
These are these the only tests we have
that show these longterm short term and
medium term metabolites.
These,
the short term in the medium term ones
that would be indicative of him taking
it recently don't exist at any point in
time during these testing.
Correct.
So this is most likely something that is
inside of his body that is an incredibly
small levels.
And is it safe to say that the detection
levels that the detection methods are
far superior today than they were a year
ago,
two years ago,
three years ago,
increase by thousands of percentage
points,
insensitivity,
I mean again,
and how recently over the last five
years.
And how recently have they,
if they improved from today versus a
year ago?
Yeah,
I believe so.
Again,
you know,
when I heard about the one pika gram
detection of the n three metabolite,
you know,
that was something that happened this
year.
I'm not aware of that ever being that
low of a number in any time in the past.
So I think,
you know,
literally week by week,
month by month as we're going here,
that level of sensitivity is increasing
exponentially.
No possible performance enhancing
benefits from these incredibly low
levels.
That's what the experts are telling me.
Look.
And again,
I'm not the expert,
I don't want to profess that I am,
but what,
what do I have to go to?
I need to go to those experts that have
made careers out of studying these
substances and the benefits and they are
all universally telling me that there's
no performance enhancing benefit.
Full compliance by jon jones in terms of
being there for usada at every single
test.
A notifying his whereabouts,
doing everything by the book.
In terms of what the ufc requires and
what you saw to require.
Yeah.
So our program has a three strike
policy.
So basically,
you know,
if you miss a test for an unexplained
reason three times,
then it could be a violation.
John's never had one whereabouts strike.
He's always been available when you saw
it as tried to test them.
And again,
especially recently,
recently one of the most tested athletes
in the ufc.
Wasn't there one test in the past where
you saw to showed up at the gym and
there was some sort of speculation that
john was hiding under the ring preview.
Sada sada before I got here.
I've heard about that at all.
The details.
I don't know whether it's true or not.
I think there's a Nevada state athletic
commission test.
My recollection's right,
but it wasn't he not a test.
Okay,
so there's no reason in terms of how
you're looking at this particular case
that this fight should not take place or
that john should be sanctioned any
further.
There isn't.
And look,
it's the least compelling argument,
but I think you know,
you have to look at it.
You have to look at the common sense
approach to this.
A guy who went through a year and a half
almost suspension to very,
I would categorize as embarrassing
public hearings in California along
arbitration hearing before mclaren.
All this science is rooted out about how
long this stuff stays in your system,
longterm metabolites for months,
maybe years.
You're going to choose to use oral
terenna ball still after going through
all that leading up to a fight.
I don't buy that.
See,
I don't think.
I think I agree with what you're saying,
but in terms of people fucking up,
there are no bounds on human stupidity
and in terms of people's ability to do
impulsive things that are irrational,
that wind up sabotaging their career is
almost more of an indication that people
are willing to do that than not.
It's very.
It's like you're less likely,
and this is in terms of especially in
particular in fighters,
fighters are ridiculously impulsive.
It's one of the things that categorizes
and it's a characteristic of the type of
human being that gets involved in that
line of work in the first place.
They're wild motherfuckers.
They're crazy.
They do crazy shit and I just.
I don't,
I don't buy that.
That would be new level crazy look.
Can I categorize this as a new level?
Crazy guy.
Least compelling argument.
I agree.
At least compelling,
but I think we'd be remiss if we didn't
at least consider that.
I.
Okay.
I see your point.
I don't buy it that that part I don't
buy.
I buy all the science and I'm a big John
Jones fan.
I mean,
you can call me a John Jones suck up all
day long.
I think he's one of the greatest of all
time and I think it's not over for him.
I think he still could reach.
I don't even think he's at his peak.
I think he's still got time to be the
greatest of all time if he hasn't
already achieved that,
but I think that he's also.
He's a wild man,
you know?
It's one of the reasons why he's so
great.
It's one of the reasons why you opened
up the fight with shogun at 22 years old
with a flying knee and he's a wild
motherfucker.
That's who he is and it's one of many
reasons besides his talent that he's so
god damn good.
I know the lows of the lows.
He's gone through these last two years.
You will have to leave.
How low those lines.
So again,
look,
I don't disagree with you that that's
not out of the area of consideration,
but man,
I,
I just don't.
I don't think anybody could be that
reckless.
I hope you're right.
I also worry that fighters often in
times,
and I'm not accusing john of doing this,
but oftentimes surround themselves with
morons and these morons give them poor
advice and these morons think that they
have ways to skirt systems and get
around the rules and they have people
that you know,
throw a bunch of fancy words their way
and they want to believe,
and this happens all the time.
This happens all the time with fighters
in regards to financial management and
advice that they get with that.
I mean I've seen like world class
fighters do ridiculous shit in terms of
strength and conditioning because some
asshole with a good vocabulary talks him
into some nonsense.
This is just one of the things that
happens with fighters and oftentimes
they can be around someone who gives him
poor advice in terms of what they can
and cannot get away with when it comes
to supplementation and when it comes to
steroid use.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I see that all over the place.
In john's case,
however,
to give credit where credit's due,
you know,
his team after the initial positive with
the dick pills was very interactive with
me and donna and checking supplements.
Hey,
what line should we go to show they,
you know,
to give them credit.
They definitely showed an increased
exercise of care when it came to
supplementation with john.
Well that's great to hear and I really
hope this is a thing of the past and I
hope this is the last time we ever have
to talk about john in this term and that
moving forward we just talk about in
terms of his performances
in his,
his fights and you know,
what?
He's already achieved the youngest sea
champion of all time.
Anything else?
Yeah,
so I was going to bring this up at the
beginning,
but the golden snitch,
that's first of all,
that's brendan shop's name.
He gave it to you,
so taken on a life of its own and I
think.
I think the last time we talked about
donna asking alexa who
see,
see what siri says.
Hold on a second.
Let's see what siri says,
but I've never tried this.
Hold on a second.
Who is the golden snitch?
He's some inflammation.
Wow.
Oh yeah.
Stitch something in Harry Potter,
which I didn't know that the last time
on.
And I mentioned I think my week of pd,
a profile it had me as aka the golden
snitch.
Somebody took that down.
Hey siri,
who is the golden snitch?
Siri.
Siri keeps going with quad itch.
So,
so someone took it down.
They do that.
Well,
I think we talked about.
You're like,
eh,
I don't know.
They just did it.
Um,
so I think I totally messed that up
already.
Coworkers call me in.
My family calls me.
They call you,
the goldens friends call me.
I was at the mma awards last year and
some yahoo had a few pops back in me is
screaming in between presentations,
the golden snitches.
I'm slinking down in my chair,
my girlfriend and I.
It is dam the golden snitches backup
already.
Do you have to see on the end of the
neck popped up?
Beautiful.
Just fucking.
When they do that,
just put your hands up in the air.
So you definitely should make a shirt
during shows.
I'll sit pretty close to the cage,
go out in between a fight into the
bathroom and it's not joe rogan level
will half the damn arena standing up.
Excited to see you walking in and out of
the fight or walk.
But two or three people in that walk
when I go backstage and check on each
side of the golden snitch.
So give them reckon.
You know steve reed,
you know,
so you've read our ball security,
that bad ass looking guy on stage.
He'll come backstage.
Just mate,
they're calling me the snitch out there,
man.
I think I'm you.
That poor guy pays for it.
Um,
we were in teams.
Is scary guy dude.
He's a great dude.
This guy is at the top of his game.
Insecurity.
Just unbelievable.
I saw him one time in las vegas during a
fight.
He was sitting on the floor.
Something's happened in the fight.
The crowd goes fucking bananas and
everybody stands up on the floor.
Steve stands up and just motions sit
down and the entire fucking section sat
down.
200 plus people.
I'm like,
if you can,
without even having to touch somebody,
just stand up by your presence alone and
control something like that.
I mean,
the best I've ever seen.
He's legit as it gets.
So are you going to do anything to
market this?
Well,
that's getting to my story.
It's not marketing,
but let me finish the story here.
So I'm in chicago this year.
I think there was a paper view.
You were there,
right?
Yes.
So something happened and I was late
getting to the arena and they had cut
off kind of the loading dock.
I couldn't get to it.
So I had my oldest daughter with me and
so we're having a walk through where all
the crowds walking in and you know,
dudes,
all the golden snitch picture,
golden snitch.
My daughter's like,
what the fuck's going on?
How old is your daughter?
So she's 22,
so two days ago,
christmas morning I'm opening up
presents.
So I get the presence for my daughters,
the three of them and my middle daughter
is very artistic and so they create
these cool sculpted beer mugs and
there's four of them.
One of them's like bald guy brewing
novitsky something and one of them says
golden snitch brewing company,
so it's cool looking thing and she,
she drew me a black and white kind of
rendition of all four,
which I'm gonna hang up.
Really cool.
So then my girlfriend's there,
so she hands me the box and she's been
telling me all along.
She goes,
I got you the best fucking president
ever in the history of presence.
I'm like,
the hell is this?
So I opened up the box.
Oh my,
she's got this series of t shirts I
think.
What size are you?
Large.
There we go,
man.
So you,
since you created it,
you literally and figuratively have to
wear it.
Now
this is outrageous.
So that picture there,
there's some.
Oh,
there we go,
baby ladies.
Gentlemen,
circle is closed.
So I posted a boot on this or something
that's picture taken.
King series,
moscow.
I think I can say this.
Hopefully they'll let me back in,
but it's out in front of kgb fsp
headquarters through that building in
the background is kgb.
F has now known as fsb.
Oh wow.
So yeah.
So I posted a picture of,
she got me like 20 shirts.
I put them on a private instagram,
facebook,
everybody in the world like take my
money man.
Where can I get one of the weigh ins
tomorrow?
Alright,
you guys created it.
You got to own it now.
I got one for shop too that you can
throw shops mad at you.
Is he?
Yeah,
he.
He called you the golden wrap now
changed.
I thought maybe you haven't been here.
He's.
He's informed.
Misinformed.
He thinks.
First of all,
you were an employee of usada.
There you go.
And that now you're an employee of the
ufc.
He's misinformed about that and I think
he.
He likes to call skeptical.
He's skeptical.
Hippo.
I am skeptical as well,
but I.
One thing that I've learned from doing
this podcast over the years is that
there's no fucking way is it's
impossible to know everything.
It is impossible
and you have to rely on the expertise of
the people who have spent a lifetime
studying these things.
It's very important.
Here's another thing.
There's no way these people could be
lying about this and it wouldn't
massively damaged their career going
forward.
It'd be done.
Someone would find out,
someone would get to them,
the other scientists,
without them,
there would be studies done,
there will be papers done.
The internet would find out about it.
Everybody would know.
There's no way.
It's pretty unprecedented in writing
with the lack of these studies that were
chenko.
One being my sanity even.
Right.
How do you say it?
Rich chenko the chicken.
It's pretty unprecedented.
And they would put these absolutes in
writing.
Um,
you know,
with this,
I think they looked at it very hard and
detailed and obviously they weren't
quick and turning it around and we would
have loved this decision to be made a
lot earlier so we could have rooted and
vetted out with Nevada.
But they did indeed,
you know,
sign their names to these pretty
absolute statements and what,
what else can the ufc and I do,
um,
when these experts are putting those
absolutes out there and I get the people
go,
oh,
whoops,
can you do.
You got to understand,
folks,
this would be career suicide.
This is,
this is the.
This is cutting edge science.
We're talking about there's too many
people that would have a vested interest
in calling bullshit.
It's not some you don't fuck around when
it comes to these things.
The people that are at the,
the front of the line when it comes to
catching people on these things in the
science that they're imploring,
they're that they're involved with.
It's this is not.
You can't like guests on the outside
with no education.
It's just not wise and this is what I
keep seeing over and over again is
people that have some knowledge,
a little bit of knowledge and they're
pretending that they are.
They have a phd in this shit
go.
I mean for those that want to do more
detective work,
go read mclaren's written decision on
john's july,
2018 july,
2018 tests.
Go read the rich hank off study on the
dhc empty and the metabolites and go
read the recent clomiphene study where
it shows as chlorinated substance.
It's pulsing,
it goes away,
comes back higher than before.
It goes away,
comes back,
lower,
goes away,
comes back higher.
Crazy stuff.
Okay.
We good?
When?
When can someone get one of these?
She only made about 15 of them for me.
So man,
you gotta sell these.
You have to sell these.
Maybe we do something for maybe do
something for charity or stuff that
jamie.
Yeah.
Someone needs to stop.
We can talk,
but then it's not exclusive.
You want to have the exclusive shirt
where nobody else can get online.
Anything exclusive.
I'm not into that man.
All right jeff,
thank you very much.
I appreciate you clarifying.
Please folks,
please have an open mind.
Please.
I know you want to call bullshit.
There's times this times to call
bullshit,
but there's
times to recognize that this is a
complicated issue and that we've laid it
out as I'm.
I'm pretty convinced.
Appreciated joe and I'm done so you
might be smarter than me.
Alright,
bye everybody.